this is London's cable car the 60
million pound boondoggle that the Mayor
of London insisted was a vital part of
the city's transport infrastructure and
here's the thing
that is a really tall cable car 19
meters if you want a cable car with a
view over the city you don't need it to
be that high why is it so tall well the
answer to that is down the river at the
qe2 bridge at the Dartford Crossing
which for many years has been the height
limit for vessels crew ships warships
coming into the city now when this cable
car was built one of the requirements
was that those ships could not be
impeded they must still be able to come
into London but here's something you
might not know this height this
expensive height here is a compromise
every meter you ratchet up the height
you also ratchet up the cost but it has
to be high enough to let those vessels
pass underneath and the thing you might
not know is that well the way they
budged it is that if a tall ship needs
to come underneath at low tide they will
remove all the gondolas and make sure
there's no passengers on board put
everything safely away so that the wire
unladen raises up enough to let boats
pass it is a bond job at best
but then that pretty much sums up the
road and that is something you might not
know
you